le maïs me 6 analystes économiques
bonsoir ici merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france
la banque mondiale qui prévoit donc une
chute de plus de 23% des transferts
d'argent vers l'afrique
quelles conséquences selon vous les
transferts de la diaspora africaine vers
le haut quand il dort sont relativement
importants ces transferts tort
généralement utilisée à des fins de
subsistance donc la conséquence d'une
interruption ou même de la réduction du
volume de transfert sera d'abord
conséquences sociales ou pour les
personnes qui les reçoit avec ils vont
voir leurs revenus de cette distance
baissé la deuxième conséquence sera une
conséquence au plan économique
du point de vue de la consommation qui
sera diversement appréciée tant de pays
seulement les pays parce que nos volumes
de transfert du point de vue monétaire
n'est pas le même en fonction des des
pays africains dans lesquels on se
trouve donc ça va être premièrement une
conséquence sociale et deuxièmement
qu'on est conséquente économique qui
découlerait de la baisse de la
consommation de ces ménages qui
viendraient amplifié les effets de la
crise que nous avons déjà observé
est ce qu'on peut imaginer également des
pertes d'emplois de salaires à partir du
moment où il y à un ralentissement de
l'économie du fait de la baisse de la
consommation
on peut effectivement penser qu'il aura
des répercussions beaucoup plus large y
compris au niveau des emplois mais d'y
copier guardian explique que la baisse
des transferts de la diaspora africaine
père le continent sera un élément de la
crise globale que nos militants
certainement pas l'élément majeur mais
un élément en amplifiant parce que la
crise en elle même par les conséquences
du pot vide les conséquences de
confinement l'eau pour des conséquences
de de ralentissement général de
l'activité économique a déjà eu des
déchets n'est pas ne serait ce que sur
l'emploi sur le chômage est également
sur les revenus des différentes et a
donc il faut un véritable cadre
économie globale à l'échelle de tous les
pays du continent et en france et que
globalement les conséquences sociales
économiques seront assez grave et
l'année 2020 bat continuelle est je
pense une année a été difficile à
beaucoup plus tard justement quelles
sont les solutions selon vous puisque
les états africains ont besoin de 105
milliards d'euros pour faire face à
cette crise c'est ce qu'indique en tout
cas là la banque mondiale les promesses
des dons extérieurs n'atteignent que 65
millions de dollars
pour l'instant je pense qu'on ne
développe pas des pays encore moins
continent par des dons ne pense que il
est à des circuits économiques
classiques ou relancer une économie ou
qui n'en c'est une économie généralement
en revanche une économie par
l'investissement par la consommation
donc ils sont arrivés à faire en sorte
que dès lors que nous serons sortis de
cette phase at est particulière et
difficile
en plus de permettre aux états d'avoir
des lectures qui permette de relancer
véritablement l'investissement dans les
pays par l'investissement va créer de
l'emploi on va créer de la croissance et
il faut trouver des moyens par des
politiques pad par des politiques
sociales pour irriguer des canaux de
façon à accroître la consommation
consommation qui fera elle tourner
l'économie et donc générera aussi de
l'emploi
je pense que cet arc et que l'on voit
uniquement par le spectre des dons c'est
une afrique du passé pour aller dans le
développement que nous espérons que les
africains attendent
il faut pas me font penser aux
politiques d'investissements qui seront
décidées par les africains quand c'est
par des africains pour les africains
est-ce que c'est finalement l'occasion
pour l'afrique d'être un tour non
justement de son destin et de se
réinventer comme vous dites je pense
effectivement que certains pays du
continent
vivement les conséquences de la crise du
pot vide vont pouvoir réinventer
certains aspects de leur vie parce que
qu'est-ce que la prise du port vite nous
apprend d'un point de vue économique ont
mis en avant
beaucoup de pays africains sont
aujourd'hui construit avec des économies
qui sont extrêmement extraverti et dès
lors qu'il y ait eu quelque part sur la
planète on a dit en europe ou en
amérique par effet consulter les pays
africains se trouvent directement
impactés donc il va falloir commencer je
crois à construire un véritable marché
africain de maintenant à ce que nous
sommes nous avions beaucoup plus
autonomes beaucoup plus dingues
interdépendants au sein de l'afrique est
beaucoup plus d'indépendance vis-à-vis
des autres parties du continent de façon
à avoir une économie beaucoup plus en
plus une économie beaucoup plus
résiliente qui permettrait au continent
d'affronter les crises avec on va dire
une meilleure armature économique est
beaucoup plus d'eux nous sommes émus de
cette solidité
je pense que certains détaillants à en
tirer les conséquences mais évidemment
certainement pas tous merci mais il sait
me 6 analystes économiques de nous avoir
apporté votre analyse ce soir